une histoire sans fin pour un homme à
bout de forces julian assange va une
nouvelle fois devoir affronter la
justice britannique les etats unis
réclament encore et toujours son
extradition pour pouvoir le juger en
janvier dernier elle la juge britannique
vanessa barre et soeurs avait rejeté
cette demande en raison du risque de
suicide de l'australien de 50 ans
évoquant sa santé mentale un état de
santé qui n'a fait que se dégrader ces
derniers mois selon sa compagne
j'ai vu giuliani hier samedi matin à la
prison de belmarsh
j'ai été déconcerté de voir à quel point
ils étaient minces il portait un tee
shirt je n'avais pas vu ses bras depuis
longtemps et j'ai pu voir à quel point
il était maigre
il avait l'air très mal en point mais
vous savez il ya eu des développements
tellement important dans la sphère au
cours des trois derniers mois que nous
espérons tous les deux que ce sera la
fin de la sphère
pour rappel le fondateur de wikileaks
risque jusqu'à 175 ans de prison aux
etats-unis si washington a pu faire
appel de cette décision c'est en grande
partie dû à ce psychiatre michael
kopelman les etats-unis mettent en cause
la fiabilité de son témoignage qui
établissait justement la santé mentale
fragile de julian assange le médecin
avait reconnu avoir trompé la justice en
dissimulant le fait que son patient
était devenu père alors qu'ils étaient
cloîtrés à l'ambassade d'équateur à
londres un argument qui a permis à la
justice américaine de revenir à la
charge pour tenter de discréditer
l'ensemble de son témoignage
les etats unis pourraient être en mesure
de convaincre la haute cour que madame
barre et soeurs a accordé trop de poids
aux rapports pour prendre sa décision
mais cela pourrait ne pas être suffisant
pour justifier l'annulation de
l'ensemble de sa décision malgré une
attaque l'avocat français du fondateur
de wikileaks à garde bon espoir
m antoine veil estime que l'appel
américain elle ne repose sur aucun
élément nouveau susceptible d'entraîner
une infirmation de la décision de
première instance quoi qu'il en soit les
soutien populaire envers julian assange
ne faiblissent pas ce week-end encore à
londres et des centaines de personnes
ont défilé dans la rue pour réclamer sa
libération munis de pancartes n extradé
pas assange ou encore le journalisme
n'est pas un crime autre événement
organisé à londres en faveur du
fondateur de wikileaks est cette
conférence intitulée le tribunal de
belmarsh en référence à la prison de
haute sécurité où est enfermé vienne
assange depuis le 11 avril 2019
plusieurs personnalités politiques et
médiatiques ont pris la parole pour
sensibiliser le monde sur l'importance
de la liberté d'expression est sur une
affaire qui pourraient façonner l'avenir
du journalisme pour les décennies à
venir
il a constamment et continuellement osé
dire l'indicible face à l'opposition
face au pouvoir et c'est une chose
remarquable est rare c'est la raison
pour laquelle julien assange est
emprisonné aujourd'hui se tait
ce qui est arrivé à julian assange était
un crime et il doit être libéré si nous
voulons libérer le monde nous devons
libérez assange merci est resté libre
libre un mot qui ne fait plus partie du
vocabulaire de vilains assange depuis
maintenant plus de dix ans cet appel qui
doit se dérouler sur deux jours
constitue l'un des derniers recours pour
washington en cas de nouvelle défaite
ils n'auraient plus comme possibilité
que de saisir la cour suprême
britannique ce qui serait synonyme pour
beaucoup d'un véritable acharnement
judiciaire aux etats-unis où la liberté
d'expression est en théorie garantie par
le premier amendement de la constitution
la statue de la liberté va si sur ces
bases